hello everybody and welcome back let's
play limbo okay so we're a little stuck
on a puzzle I know that people are I'm
done I'm done with that forgive and
forget
forgive and forget those backstabbing
bastards forgive and forget
how they insulted me all right thanks so
basically I got to find how to get that
lever to go the other way
so I don't I've already gone up there so
I haven't I didn't lose anything or I
didn't miss it so if I I just need to
get that lever balance huh ah teepees
box up there but how do I do that
it's really pathetic that I can't jump
up and reach at that that's really
really sad for this guy come on where's
your 68 inch vertical come on what the
hell man yeah here I push you away got
to deck so that's there god it gets his
lever hmm
yeah okay there must be something else
down in the under way I must have missed
something so I will go back in a long
arduous circle odd it's got a great oh
no I did the guys that actually did one
thing that didn't kill me that I hope
all right let's go looking
let's go exploring no I'm wasting time
Oh No
the solution was probably obvious oh no
oh no maybe there's some debris that
fell when I wrote that bridge that I
could drown then pool alone probably
probably no not that no not that no not
there no not that no no can't told
anything here no mm-hmm this is all bad
nope okay
no no good and you're going back nothing
I can grab nothing I can grab nothing I
can grab
I suppose not okey-dokey
so the obvious solution must be right
there in front of my face somehow
somehow I must solve it but how Oh II so
anyway I Boosh you push the box hmm
how to make that not be stupid hmmmm
there's nothing I can get because I
can't even lift it off that how to do
how do I do
oh I know how I know I know I know I
know
oops that's not right I know I know I
know I know
I bushi i bruise you and then i get you
and then i pull you back and then I
climb on you and then I jump up there oh
no no wait yeah okay I got it
and what what's this what did stood
there did yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I
got a oh no
yeah oh yeah I'm the bear what was that
Oh how do I go where do I do for me what
do I do ah damn it
I don't know how that
one second hang on how about the Boosh
I feel you hmm ya Yin we really pull
versioning good
Emma's you a bishop oh I've put you down
mm-hmm hey abuse you
about about oh yeah oh yeah I'm the best
in bed there ever was oh yeah it's
something fell out of that so I gotta ah
damn it not again
alright I am failing it up I'm failing
pretty hardcore here though I just
dropped off then forget Daniel Jim Furyk
I move you put attractive thing
not a word not a word not a word or lest
you concur my wrath
a vicious I miss you ever shoot I got
this don't worry I got this guys I got
it I got it I got it I got it I got it
I'm a speech in the booth
did I jump I jump on you
I got swing back to that ledge the night
jump if oh yeah wait whoops what do I do
now
ah yeah oh yeah I go get to thingy and
then that somehow leads me to going
forward yeah yeah oh yeah yeah dummy
coming ah oh just an achievement thing
ah dang it dang it
wait I meant no no wait a minute
hmm
what a simple mechanical lever how can
it be so hard earth damn it hmm all
right what am I doing wrong
gotta be something I'm doing wrong hey
over here
anything anything at all wrong with me
we're drawing not a word wrong with me
you gotta get the box I just went to
Bucks
I did one two bucks urgent one the birds
mmm why can I grab this why why can I
grab this
why is he's grabbed a boo-boo Sh
no that's wrong
go get up
if i grab it i bill you you're not going
down there for i bull you not that what
did that do
why does this do for me this does
nothing maybe
No
huh I build you you can't have it it's
mine no I bill you damn you baby hang on
chipton fetish Neitzel I have an idea it
is a glorious idea ah I've got you your
may know you belong to me oh this
totally it touch it man Oh totes it Oh
totes it man
and then I I fully want oh yeah oh oh
the genius now oh so smart
oh so smart oh the best oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah and shut up
shop shop hotel Oh what now what is this
oh yeah I got it I don't know what I'm
doing now but I got it uh yeah I got
shot
oh yeah oh I know I know I need to pull
the lever and you - strong oh yeah the
best but there was oh yeah oh yeah oh
the best
oh the best
oh btw yeah oh yeah oh yeah [ __ ] this oh
oh oh oh oh I miss you I miss you I miss
you on the grid and food
all right it was a good day ah back him
up Oh Bob yeah great Gretch shut up ha
ha
yeah come on come on come on down at my
game I'm gonna tag a nerd in the river
okay I needed one Mississippi
deuce mrs. Geary don't crush me in the
head aah
make that I don't know but here we go oh
oh oh oh so smart on the best oh look
how awesome aqua what was that what was
that
me no likey whatever that was ah what
the hell it oh girl I'm a big monster I
dare you I scare you can't see me maybe
I have to ride bush ah damn it
hmm
sneak sneak I sneak acne Q ethnic ethnic
I got River ah - shut up
I got this hmm hey hey hey I had a hand
in here can't see me I'm heeding I am so
sneaky
mmm after you do we so I need to ride
that thing or get up there canteen I'm
in the tall grass you can't see me in
the tall grass for some reason that
guides me in every way shut up shut up
come on yeah man uh little dead bird
you scared me I'd be scared me too mmm
there's nothing for me to push or
fooling miss that body that body no I
cannot hmm yeah war Oh No
okay okay all right
anyway I'm out of time for now I'll
figure this out in the next episode so
thank you so much for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next part
and shop bye-bye